تعود قصه الجمعه السوداء الى الازمه
الماليه في الولايات المتحده عام
1869 والتي شكلت ضربه الكبرى للاقتصاد
الامريكي حيث تقدست البضائع وتوقفت حركه
البيع والشراء ما سببك كارثه الاقتصاديه
في امريكا تعافت منها عن طريق اجراء
تخفيضات كبرى على السلع والمنتجات لبيعها
وتقليل الخسائر قدر المستطاع ومنذ ذلك
اليوم اصبح تقليد في امريكا تقوم كبرى
المتاجر والمحل والوكلات باجراء تخفيضات
كبرى على منتجاتها تصل الى 90% من قيمتها
لتعود بعد ذلك اليوم الى سعرها الطبيعي
بعد انقضاءه
اما وصف هذا اليوم باللون الاسود فقط
اعطيت هذه التسميه اول مره في عام 1960 من
قبل الشرطه مدينه فيلادلفيا حيث كانت تظهر
اختناقات مروريه كبيره وتجمع وطوابير
طويله امام المحلات فالطوابير الطويله
والزحام المتدافع والسمه الاساسيه للجمعه
السوداء في وصفت اداره الشرطه في مدينه
فيلادلفيا هذاك اليوم بالجمعه السوداء
لوصفه تلك الفوضى والازدحامات في حلقه
المرور من مشاهير وسيارات
والمحاسبه حيث يدل على الربح والتخلص من
الموجود في المستودعات بينما يعبر اللون
الاحمر على الخساره والعجز اما المرشح
واستخدام الحبر الاسود لتسجيل الارباح
والحبر الاحمر لتسجيل الخسائر في دفتري
حسابات الارباح والخسائر اليوميه
الامريكيه وكانتيجه لتحقيق ارباح كبيره في
ذلك اليوم وامتلاء الدفاتر باللون الاسود
تم تسميته بالجمعه السوداء
[موسيقى]